I just step off and died is that you it
right there yeah this is so sketchy
it's wild right and she always just
falls between the cars
that's her there's no wires thanks to
our sponsor Skillshare stick around to
the end of this video to find out how
you can get two months free of premium
membership hi welcome back to another
episode of stunt men and stud women
react we're here with Amy Johnson who is
both an actress and an incredible
fighter on screen she's gonna break down
some awesome stuff for us today I'm so
excited to be the first woman I just
gotta say we've had the privilege of
working with Amy and a couple different
projects in the past you can see Amy
specializing in her craft when she was
being piggyback carried by another stunt
man with guns take both our legs and
arms oh are you crazy
that is a terrible terrible
oh my god just know yeah that was killed
yeah he's strong man I can't help but
think that this is Norman Reedus in that
math I'm playing a lot of des trainings
have you guys seen this maybe yeah yeah
Clayton hasn't seen anything is this is
this endgame this is the Winter Soldier
man this is the one with the elevator
with Dean yeah he was in this yeah he
did the elevator scene fell asleep no
there oh yeah he did he doesn't have a
lot kills
[Music]
so I really liked this highway scene
there's a lot going on so we shot this
in so many different shots first was a
shot in front of a green screen with a
car hanging and we fell onto a mat on
the side of the door is that you it
right there yeah okay so they've done
like a Scarlett Johansson face replace
and then Chris Evans actually did this
which was awesome really he looks so
scared the next shot a truck was pushing
us with us laying on the highway on a
door
the truck was pushing that door down the
highway it would release us we would
like fly off of this ramp so that we
could get that air for the land that's
for real you guys are actually real that
was us like sliding down the highway we
were hinged initially to the truck that
was pushed and then they would release
us and then we were all by ourselves
that we could get like that Top Shot
there was a car like that and that was
rolling in front of us it wasn't like it
sounds really scary yeah I was wild we
were just like sledding down the highway
this is so sketchy
it's wild break I know there's a car
like flying in front of us how do you
that's not a separate take no no what's
happening at once it was so cool yeah
and how they put it together was amazing
how many pads do you ever on your angles
well for the ankles we usually just have
like a little bit on the sides and then
thankfully I had like pants on and a
jacket so I could pad everything I
wanted but yeah usually women don't get
to wear many pads cuz we're not wearing
much clothes so that's something very
different from stunt men and stunt women
you're the whole barbarian armor thing
to deal with huh yeah I'm so used to
seeing CG in Marvel movies but that's
like so you guys actually on the rolling
car there you're actually skating down
the highway that's something I really
love about this film is that they do a
lot of practical effects and and the
martial arts was more grounded that's
you do a lot of like hand-to-hand
fighting as opposed to more extreme
superhero stuff did any guys fall off
the door in the me point yeah so
actually it's Erin Tony's fantastic
stunt performer oh man oh yeah it was
super serious no covering on his arms no
I know cuz he had that shirt poor thing
like oh I believe he had like a small
ice-skating pods
kind of clear a little bit of padding
around I have a dumb production question
like you rent out a freeway I guess and
then you destroy it by scraping it like
you have to fix it men and construction
workers react that was the other double
Heidi and then this connects into me so
this was cool that was all green screen
behind me
we had like a rope tied to my arm did
like a little loop and then I was just
like standing on a platform I jumped off
and was green screen behind me and I
ended up looking amazing and then they
did a face replacement was it hard to
run in Scarlett Johansson's boots like
did you have to run in those high-heeled
boots yeah we always have to run in
high-heeled boots or high heels so we're
constantly in uncomfortable clothing yes
crazy didn't get aware I like these
mercenary outfit you know mask fool
everything they're working motorcycle
pads for some reason it's just what they
always work yeah and then the women are
in like a little little shorts or
whatever so yeah a little difficult
you should really watch this film
there's a lot of cool give me so much
trouble if you are enjoying the show and
you want to see more of these episodes
please consider subscribing to the
coridor crew channel helps us out and
helps you out because we get you the
videos you want even quicker this is one
of my all-time favorite action films
because it's a love story and an action
film beautifully shot directed a li like
this is one of my favorites what do you
guys think of like the the floaty floaty
wire work do you like that I honestly
first we actually not a fan more of a
fan of like you know the Jackie style
more grounded style but it man uses a
little bit of that floaty wire stuff a
little bit not as much as this but I
think like it's it's it doesn't bother
me anymore like I feel like I can
appreciate anything at this point what
about yourself I love it so much I
really like that into the Badlands like
implemented that that style and we got
like Americans got to see that more
because I think there's a time for it
and it works really well I think it's
kind of like just magical why do you
think this these sword fights read so
much better than most sword fights on
film there's a lot of wide-shots cuz the
stunt doubles or the actors know what
they're doing so you can actually see
what's going on as opposed to like
you're the cheetah yeah I did yeah the
choreography is stunning like the
moments are great there's not a lot of
like ghost hits like everything is
connecting everything has an intention
and purpose and there's a lot of back
and forth so one character is going that
way the other characters going that way
like there's a story in the dance of the
choreography
[Music]
Michelle Yeoh has done a lot of like
action in the past she started at a
young age to do a lot of action she was
a dancer but in this scene she actually
has a torn ACL Michelle Yeoh does really
she tore her ACL in one of the very
first fight scenes and so she had to
recover and fortunately like she's still
de great in these tight shots but if you
look she's not moving very much unless
you get that top shot of the stunt
double so she still maintained all of
her fight scenes and like did everything
you know that she could with a torn ACL
what a trooper smiled yeah yeah was it
Michelle Yeoh the one that takes like
the the windshield hit that one Jackie
Chan clip and then the wind chill
doesn't break and she falls off into the
road oh this Supercop Supercop is that
michelle yeoh that was michelle yeoh
[Music]
[Applause]
Michell and the cars in the background
it's like something avoid not running
over the lead actress in the film Jackie
Chan's just like oh my god she did that
train jump herself didn't she
no wait no no all right so that all
right there that's got to be her wait
what what Michelle Yeoh
okay and she always just falls between
the cars like that's straight up you
miss it you die okay she has to have
been on wires right there's the there's
outtakes mm-hmm that's her that's her
that's crazy that's her for sure taking
the jump that's her there's no wires
these all burn that one but that was her
yeah yeah she looks very floaty let me
show you oh I had never driven a
motorcycle before she filmed this crazy
movie stunt that's got to be a double
yeah there's no way if you've never
wrote a dirt bike been a long time
there's a really cool action scene or
even just a stunt that you want us to
take a look at we will bring a
professional on the show and we will
have them break it down for you but you
have to leave a comment about what that
scene is first so that we know what you
seem to break down
Oh
oh yeah this guy no he's great we
brought him over from Indonesia
his name is Chet chip he recalled me
ketchup we did this recently after the
raid kind of like hit big and we're like
yeah let's let's do some more of that
[Music]
hey you know these guys Zen and Malay
who are - my like favorite people ever
Zen MLI where the the robots in our Far
Cry blood dragon know he's half robot
he's more of a cyborg your Android
oh yeah
oh you let me kick anyway that's so good
it's so brutal so are you doing the
thing we're like and you go to kick
somebody you don't just rock kick
somebody right you do the thing where
you like go like place it a little bit
of both yeah cuz like for this he had he
was wearing something so I can actually
kick him and it was a shot where we
wanted you to see that I was kicking him
sure sure I definitely like kingdom
brunel yeah boom
the choreography is legit
usually there's one voice like chechik
would be the one voice and then we would
know the scenario and each person would
kind of like come up with moves that
work for their body yeah we'd all come
together and chechik would have the last
say and that's how it works a lot of
times on on bigger films is like the
stunt performer stunt doubles work on
movements that they feel comfortable
with get like a bunch of little
vignettes yeah and then show the
coordinator choreographer and then kind
of like work from there
how long do you guys have to practice
this fight scene four before you could
this we rehearsed once for a couple
hours cuz he's great when you have like
a dance partner that knows what they're
doing you just come together and he's
salsa for sure that dude was really
letting me hit him that was awesome he
was so enjoy harder a lot of gushing
blood there yeah yeah wasn't a good day
for him that's super cool so I hope
everyone's happy and healthy these days
I know a lot of us are gonna be working
from home for the next few weeks so I
challenge you guys to better yourselves
with today's sponsor Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creatives who are ready to
take their skills to the next level I
assume that most of you guys are here
because you enjoy learning just like
myself it's not the matrix you can't
just magically know how to do something
you have to take the time to learn so
Skillshare makes it super easy to do
that now Skillshare offers a ton of
different videos and tutorials for
example if you guys want to learn more
about today like photography
Craig Whitehead actually has a really
good class titled street photography
unlocking the secrets to composition
color and confidence any literally
anything that you guys want to learn you
can learn on Skillshare cinematography
visual effects design illustration self
help if Fitness they make it super easy
for everybody all skill levels and these
videos are bite-size good for any
schedule so with a skill share
membership you get full unlimited access
to every single one of their classes
membership is less than ten dollars a
month and you know what honest guys
we're offering a two month free trial of
the Skillshare premium membership to the
first 500 people so go ahead click that
link down in the description get your
learn on you got plenty of time these
days you know it's the perfect thing to
do when you are social distancing
yourself from the rest of society so
let's get that learning on guys chances
are if you're watching this series you
enjoy stunts and learning about the
world stunts Amy here is actually
written a book
how to stud in Hollywood insight and
advice and world class some
professionals you can get on Amazon and
get it for Kindle apparently there's an
audiobook that you're working on as well
if you are interested in getting into
the industry or you just want to learn
more about stunts it's a really cool
book to to check out I'm going to pick
up a copy I think also if you want to
follow more of Amy's work you can check
her out on Instagram her handle as Amy e
Johnston well a link to all this in the
description below of the book the
Instagram and other cool clips things
that she's been in here on corridor it's
all there so if you want to watch more
read more whatever it's all in the
description but Amy it's been an
absolute pleasure having you on the show
thank you for all the awesome insight
and showing us these really cool scenes
that you've been a part of it's honestly
it's an honor and a privilege to be able
to sit next to you and have you talk
about it please it's an honor and
privilege to be here thanks guys really
he's probably good but these guys have
to edit it